lockdowns
curfews
high numbers of infections
a new variant of the coronavirus is once
again keeping the world in suspense
despite the vaccinations
numbers of infections are breaking
records
more than half of the european
population are expected to contract
omicron rumors and fake news about the
virus variant spread almost as quickly
as omicron itself
one of them is
omicron is harmless
misleading
social networks are full of claims that
omicron is significantly less dangerous
than previous variants
some even think we don't really have to
worry anymore
fact is the omicron variant seems to
lead to somewhat milder courses
in countries like great britain and
south africa for example the number of
infections has exploded but hospital
admissions and severe cases have not
increased as much as feared
omicron also has some biological
differences from the previous variants
some studies point to the fact that it
may actually prefer the upper
respiratory tract compared to the lower
one the lungs which might explain
why it is very contagious obviously if
there's a lot of virus up here
in the in the upper airway it's very
easily spread
but then less likely to cause severe
disease simply because it doesn't prefer
the lung
as it's it's a place to to replicate and
to infect but that doesn't mean we can
sit back and relax south africa for
example had two advantages during the
omicron wave that do not necessarily
apply to other countries
first
many south africans already had basic
immunity through previous illness or
vaccination and secondly the population
is comparatively young
it's definitely not possible to to claim
that omicron is simply a common cold
virus
indeed if you have good immunity that
means you are fully vaccinated and and
you become infected with omicron
the disease you will develop very likely
resembles a common cold so it is
unpleasant but it's not a danger um
for those who are
totally un non-immune um we you know the
chances are it may be milder but but you
know you can still have very severe
disease and even difference
some vaccination opponents even go so
far as to claim that the new virus
variant is much more contagious for
those who have been vaccinated
allegedly after three months the vaccine
efficacy of biotech pfizer and moderna
becomes negative against the omicron
variant
the vaccinated are more likely to become
infected than the unvaccinated false
a study from denmark that has not yet
been peer reviewed has led to some
confusion according to opponents of the
vaccination it confirms that the corona
vaccines are useless and can even be
harmful
the study addresses the question of how
well the vaccines from biotech pfizer
and moderna protect against an infection
with omicron the researchers calculated
the effectiveness by comparing the
infection rates of those who had been
vaccinated twice and those who had not
been vaccinated at all
the studies took place during the first
few weeks after omicron was detected in
denmark
in fact in the study the effectiveness
of the vaccine drops to negative levels
after three months
but how can that be
we spoke to one of the authors about
this
firstly because it would be a very odd
mechanism by which
you
have protection in the first few months
after
vaccination and then the vaccines flip
to becoming harmful in some sense and
the fact that the the fourth estimate is
is uh negative so this is after uh 90 90
days
um
is really a sign that there is some bias
in the comparisons of the infection
rates in the vaccinated versus the
unvaccinated populations
these statistical distortions have to do
with the different behavior of the
vaccinated and the unvaccinated explains
holm hansen
for example vaccinated and recovered
people can travel abroad more easily and
that's how omicron came to denmark
this group can also take part in events
more easily which leads to a higher risk
of infection
it's also important to consider that 80
percent of the population in denmark has
now been fully vaccinated
when when you have a situation like that
um
the you would tend to see
more
infections in the vaccinated populations
not because the vaccines aren't
protective but because
the
omicron epidemic hasn't quite yet
spread far enough into the population
it's not general the epidemic is not
generalized enough in the population
to really have
comparable infection rates in the
vaccinated and unvaccinated
so the negative values after three
months do not mean that the unvaccinated
are better armed against omicron than
the vaccinated this is also clearly
indicated in the study itself
the vaccinations are not effective
against omicron
false
initial studies show that basic
immunization usually with two doses of
vaccine offers little or no protection
against infection with the omicron
variant
this is because all previous mrna
vaccines were based on the blueprint of
the spike protein of the original
coronavirus
the spike proteins of the new virus
variant have numerous mutations
as a result our immune system no longer
recognizes the omicron variant so well
the antibodies can no longer bind and
neutralize the new variant at an early
stage
the virus penetrates the cells faster
and can multiply there
but that doesn't mean the vaccinations
are useless they still protect from a
severe course of the disease to a high
degree and then there are booster
vaccinations in a study scientists from
harvard found that they significantly
increased protection against omicron
right it's very clear that the vaccine
in particular once you receive your
third chat you are also
very likely to be protected at least for
some time for getting infected but it's
really clear that the pros that all the
vaccines
protect for getting seriously ill the
vaccinations together with contact
restrictions and hygiene rules are
therefore the best form of protection
against omicron
[Music]